- Wait, what the heck?
Why do you-- why do
both of you think that?
I mean, okay guess I'm learning
things about myself today.
(playful music)
We are here to see who knows me best,
my boyfriend or my dad.
- So we're figuring out
who knows me better,
my mom or my boyfriend Carlos.
- My boyfriend Dakota
and I have been together
for about four and a half years.
- Carlos and I have been dating
for two years and a week.
'Cause we just had our
anniversary last week.
- I would say he knows me
way better than my dad,
my dad has obviously been there for like,
all those monumental life moments,
but all the details and
the nitty-gritty stuff about my life,
my boyfriend definitely knows me better.
- After you date somebody for a while,
you just kinda like--
lives just start to meld.
- I hope Dakota would, if he doesn't know
the majority of things
about me that kinda sucks.
We've been together for so long.
- I feel like they're gonna be very mixed,
like my mom is probably
gonna go with like,
answers that would have
applied when I was like 12.
And then my boyfriend knows me better now.
- My dad and I are really close.
I go down to see him every single weekend.
We spend like, almost
every single meal together
when I'm down there.
- So my mom and I are really close,
we talk pretty much everyday.
I call her like, every
single break that I have.
I don't know why, like,
I don't consider myself a momma's boy
but looking at it from
an outsider perspective,
I probably am.
- Let's see who wins.
(upbeat music)
- Question number one.
What is my favorite meal?
- Did you write it?
- That's not a meal, actually.
- Okay I didn't know this
was that hard of a question.
- You guys ready?
Three, two one.
No, what?
(laughter)
That's your favorite food.
This is not gonna go well.
- One, two, three.
Oh, what? (laughs)
- That was a close guess though.
- Yeah she eat that every morning.
- Yeah, that's why this
question is so hard
is 'cause she changes
her mind all the time.
So it's not what she
has liked, historically.
- Historically? (laughs)
- It's like, what're
you feeling right now?
So for lunch you wanna get poke,
is that what you're saying?
- Yeah.
- Okay.
- If I won the lottery, what's
the first thing I would buy?
I feel like it's really easy.
(laughs)
- That's not hard.
- Okay we gotta start off slow
and then we'll get into the hard ones.
You get too confident and then
it's gonna bite you in the butt later.
- Okay.
(laughs)
- You're answering really
quickly I feel like you're not
- I don't want to overthink it.
- Yeah you're not thinking.
(laughs)
- It better be this answer,
if its not I didn't teach you too well.
- I don't know anymore, it's
making me nervous. (laughs)
- Three, two, one.
A house and clothes.
(laughs)
Okay.
- C'mon you know you'd buy a house.
- So it's zero, zero. Alright.
(laughs)
Great.
- One, two, three.
Oh yeah, it's a house!
- Father knows best.
(laughs)
- And boyfriend.
- What's my favorite way to
relax and recharge my batteries?
I guess 'cause I don't, no
one knows how to answer it.
(laughs)
- I'm still not overthinking this.
Don't overthink it Wolfie.
- Oh, it's easy.
- I feel like my handwriting's
getting sloppier now.
(laughs)
- This is not going well,
I am now putting myself up
for adoption and then single.
(laughs)
And three, two, one.
- Oh, I put (laughs)
- Well that actually
would be the right answer.
- Meditation!
- Wait I wanna change mine,
- Oh shit!
because that's actually true.
I didn't-- but meditating on the beach.
- See, we know you more
than you know yourself.
- Yeah, you know me better
than I know me. Clearly.
- Oh, I put sleep, babe.
- Yeah I know, you guys both got a point.
- One to one. Yeah!
- That was good.
I'll have to do some
introspective time after this.
- Would I consider myself more
of an introvert or extrovert?
I feel like that one's pretty easy.
- What if I just throw it
and write the wrong one?
(laughs)
Three, two, one.
Extrovert.
(laughs)
- Oh dang.
- I got it wrong.
- Are you serious?
- One, two, three.
What?
- Yeah.
- Wait, what the heck?
Why do you-- why do
both of you think that?
- Because regularly people
think that you're an extrovert,
but actually--
- Exactly.
- You're a natural introvert.
- You like to spend time with yourself.
- I mean, okay guess I'm learning
things about myself today.
- What do you think is my worst trait?
I don't like that question.
(laughs)
feel free to offend me, we'll see.
- Okay.
(laughs)
- What do we think, or what do you think?
- What do I think?
- You ready? You can show it.
- I didn't answer this, um--
- Grouchiness?
(laughs)
That is so mean!
- He's a kiss up.
- I had to win.
It's two-one.
- I'm not grouchy.
- Oh, you're never grouchy.
- What? No, Carlos gets that point.
Can he get that point?
- Oh, Dakota got it.
I'm too bossy. (laughs)
Are you sad 'cause I
boss you around a lot?
- What type of adventure would I prefer?
A spontaneous one or a
carefully planned out one?
- Do you feel confident about this?
- Very confident.
- Yes.
- One, two, three.
What?
- Oh, you got it.
- Why'd you put spontaneous?
- Well 'cause you like to be spontaneous.
You want me to plan things out for you
and just kinda let you...
- No but--
- But it's still planned out.
- I'm planning it out but
for you it's spontaneous.
Because you have no idea.
- I mean I guess, but I need
someone to plan something.
- Planned, yeah.
- Planned. Ding.
- What frightens me most?
- There's no multiple choice answer?
- No. (laughs)
And you only choose one.
- Wait, only one?
- Yeah, do you think I'm
scared of multiple things?
Well, frightened.
Frightened is different than scared.
- That's easy.
- You think it's easy.
- I don think either of you will get it.
- Okay.
- So you're just writing anything?
Great.
(laughs)
- [Woman] You're still thinking
about it after you wrote it?
(laughs)
- Yeah, I'm ready.
- Okay. One, two, three.
I put my dad.
Spiders?
- I actually probably
should have guessed that.
- Yeah.
- But you're scared of this all the time.
- Yeah, but I'm scared of you more.
- No that's respect.
- No. (laughs)
- On three, two, one.
- I'm rather boring here.
- Alright.
(laughs)
- Oh you got it!
- [Debbie] Disappointing others.
- Only you spelled
disappointing right, I didn't.
- Did I spell it...
- [Man] So yeah, you got it right.
- Wow. What a deep profound answer.
I was gonna put like,
- That was impressive.
- black cats or something.
- (laughs) Black cats.
- Why would I be scared of-- I love cats.
- I guess I didn't even want
to take a risk on that one.
- Father's know best, I'm telling you.
- Four and a half years and
you can't even win a game.
So sorry.
- Alright I did pretty good though.
- Yeah you did, you actually did.
- We were neck and neck.
- And some of these
questions were hard actually.
- Yay.
Well done.
I'm actually very
surprised that my dad won.
I'm surprised they could both
answer some of the questions.
'Cause I felt like some
of them were really hard
and like super, super specific.
- Sorry Debbie.
- Well done Carlos.
- It was a good attempt.
You both know me better
than I know myself. (laughs)
So that was the important part.
- So yeah, I'm surprised.
- I'm not surprised.
- I guess we are closer
than I think we are. (laughs)
- I'm not surprised.
- Okay the game's over you
don't have to be mean to each other.
(laughs)
(playful music)